good morning believe nation today's
message is leadership is not personality
over you Jim Collins one thing we have
to be very clear on is that leadership
is not personality some leaders do have
charisma but a lot of the very best
leaders that we studied in the course of
history had what I might call a charisma
bypass and they are not people who would
jump across a table at you some of them
can be almost strange in their behavior
some of them can be magnetic in their
behavior some of them can be harsh and
abrasive in their behaviors and when you
when you look at all that you say well
wait a minute leadership is not
personality and in fact if you're highly
charismatic that's not necessarily a
positive because the critical thing we
found about how people engage with a
leader is not about this external stuff
that's really pretty irrelevant it has
to do with the answer to a simple
question why are you in it are you
fundamentally doing something that's
about you or are you trying to build
something great to accomplish something
great to build great products or whether
to be a build a great company or to
change a bunch of kids lives in a school
or to accomplish a mission in
Afghanistan I mean if it's fundamentally
about you as a leader why should anybody
give themselves over to what you're
trying to do but if it's fundamentally
that you're channeling your ego into a
cause or a company or a set of work or
something that you're trying to
accomplish that is not about you that's
when people will sign up so what do you
think I think there's a lot of truth in
what he said in his message you know at
first when I was watching the clip I was
like what what's this guy talking about
of course you know there are
natural-born leaders of course being a
strong value-based leader is something
that that you're born with its
personality based and I totally
disagreed with him until like halfway
through the clip and then I was like ah
I get what this guy's saying and then by
the end I was like yeah it has nothing
to do with personality because if you
have a set of values if you have a goal
if you if you live outwardly if your
mission is bigger than you then of
course you'll get people to follow if
you're someone who doesn't like to speak
if you're an introvert if you if you are
an extrovert if if no matter what your
personality is if you're trying to do
something bigger than you people will
follow they'll get on board I think
entrepreneurs we tend to look at super
successful entrepreneurs who are in the
media and feel like I need to be like
them to be successful you may look at
Steve Jobs they well he's so charismatic
or look at Oprah and she's so
charismatic and feel like oh I'm an
introvert and I'm not charismatic I
can't be successful like them or I need
to be like them and I need to force
myself to be someone I'm not to have
success where if you look at the
billionaires right if you take out all
the people who've inherited wealth and
ones who've just become wealthy because
of entrepreneurship a lot of them you
could you couldn't name like a lot of
them would not be recognizable names to
you because there's a lot of different
ways to build a business and the ones
that stand out are the ones who are
using their voice because they're really
good at it right you know Oprah because
she's using her strength her voice to be
a leader but there's a lot of people
we've never heard of who used their
introverted leadership skills to be
successful as well and so for me the key
message is you want to be yourself right
I mean you're building a business to do
something that you want to be proud of
you're building it for your community
and not just for your own ego but to go
all in on your strengths and if you are
an outgoing extroverted person then be
that but if you're introverted
analytical and detail-oriented then go
all in on that and don't try to be
someone who you're not because if you
try to that do you won't have success
one thing I just quickly add is when we
look at other people we're seeing the
veneer we're seeing the outside we're
seeing what they put into the world we
don't see their heart we don't see their
mind we don't see their fears or
challenges so when you're living you
when you're being yourself you're
putting you're putting yourself out
there it's best not to compare yourself
against all those people who seem so
good at things but we're not in their
mind we don't really understand what
they're working
day to day I love it so the question
today today is what's the one area of
leadership that you want to work on
leaving the comments below will join the
discussion thank you so much for
watching have an amazing day continue to
believe and we'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot of espresso oh
wait